This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The best James Bond is either Sean Connery or Daniel Craig. I lean towards Daniel Craig. The new movies are just better. But the Sean Connery films definitely had the best villains. There's Blowfeld, of course, who's so iconic that he turned the act of cat stroking into a thing that super villains do.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。最好的詹姆斯·邦德要么是肖恩·康纳利，要么是丹尼尔·克雷格。我更倾向于丹尼尔·克雷格。新电影确实更好。但肖恩·康纳利的电影绝对拥有最好的反派。当然还有布洛菲尔德，他太经典了，以至于他把抚摸猫咪的动作变成了超级反派的标配。
But Bond's flashiest nemesis has to be gold finger. Do you expect me to talk? No, Mr. Bond, I expect you to die! Do you expect me to talk? Yeah, I expect you to talk. There's this dorky fun fact that the Bond villain, Goldfinger, was actually named after a real person.
但邦德最招摇的宿敌一定是金手指。你指望我说出真相吗？不，邦德先生，我指望你去死！你指望我说出真相吗？是的，我指望你说出真相。有一个书呆子式的趣闻，邦德反派“金手指”的名字其实是取自一个真实的人。
That's truffleman, a very truffle. The author of the James Bond books, Ian Fleming, named Goldfinger for a man he found so dastardly, so terrible that he immortalized him in pop culture. The real Goldfinger was an architect, Erno Goldfinger, and he made giant, hulking, austere, concrete buildings. Goldfinger's buildings were decreed sole lists. inhabitants claimed to suffer health problems and depression from spending time inside them. some of Goldfinger's buildings were vacated because occupants found them so ugly.
那是特鲁夫曼，一个非常特鲁夫曼。詹姆斯·邦德系列小说的作者伊恩·弗莱明以一个他认为极其卑鄙、极其糟糕的人的名字命名了金手指，并将他永载于流行文化之中。现实中的金手指是一位建筑师，名叫埃尔诺·戈德芬格，他建造了巨大、笨重、严苛的混凝土建筑。戈德芬格的建筑被判定为“社会主义风格”。住户们声称，待在里面会导致健康问题和抑郁。戈德芬格的一些建筑因为住户觉得太丑而被弃用。
and yet many architects praised Goldfinger's buildings. his trellic tower, which was once threatened with demolition, has been awarded landmark status. This divide, this hatred from the public and love from designers and architects, tends to be the narrative around buildings like gold fingers, which is to say gigantic, imposing buildings made of concrete. What some people refer to as brutalist architecture. And a lot of folks beyond the creator of James Bond love to hate them. We are in Worcester Hall, which to my great-dismay illustration is often considered the worst building on campus or
然而，许多建筑师却称赞戈德芬格的建筑。他设计的特雷利克塔曾面临拆除威胁，但后来被授予了地标地位。这种分歧——公众的厌恶与设计师及建筑师的喜爱——往往是围绕像金手指这类建筑的叙事，也就是说，由混凝土建造的巨大、宏伟的建筑。有些人称之为粗野主义建筑。除了詹姆斯·邦德的创作者之外，很多人也喜欢讨厌它们。我们现在在伍斯特大厅，据我非常沮丧的观察，它通常被认为是校园里最糟糕的建筑，或者
Worcester Hall, more like Worst. I met up with Sarah Briggs Ramsey in Worcester Hall, a brutalist building at UC Berkeley. I can't tell you how many times I've been locking up my bike outside and I over here undergrads, walking with their parents and going, ironically, this is the architecture school and it's the ugliest building on campus. Yep, Worcester Hall is the architecture school. Sarah completed her masters there. Buildings like this are pretty pervasive across most American and Canadian campuses.
伍斯特大厅，简直是“最差大厅”。我在加州大学伯克利分校的粗野主义建筑伍斯特大厅见到了莎拉·布里格斯·拉姆齐。我数不清有多少次在外面锁自行车时，听到本科生带着父母走过来说：“讽刺的是，这是建筑学院，却是校园里最丑的建筑。”没错，伍斯特大厅就是建筑学院。莎拉在那里完成了她的硕士学位。像这样的建筑在大多数美国和加拿大的校园里非常普遍。
Yeah, there was a big bulky concrete building on the campus where I went to college. And I hated when I had to go through it. It just reminded me of a bunker or a bomb shelter. These big concrete buildings just like bum me out. Absolutely. I mean, it has these connotations of, you know, Soviet era construction, sometimes third world construction, all these negative associations. This is Professor Adrian 40, author of the excellent book Concrete and Culture. He's been researching concrete for around 10 years now. It has a bad name.
是的，我上大学的校园里也有一座又大又笨重的混凝土建筑。我讨厌必须穿过它的时候。它只会让我想起地堡或防空洞。这些巨大的混凝土建筑让我感到沮丧。绝对是这样。我的意思是，它带有苏联时代建筑的内涵，有时是第三世界建筑的内涵，所有这些负面的联想。这是阿德里安·福蒂教授，优秀著作《混凝土与文化》的作者。他研究混凝土已经大约10年了。它名声不好。
Apart from aesthetic criticisms, concrete buildings present environmental concerns. A lot of these buildings built at a time when energy was cheap and they used up an awful lot of energy to heat and cool them. Concrete buildings were built with the illusion of plenty, that we will always have enough energy to build and heat and cool these massive inefficient structures. As harsh as it looks, concrete is an utterly optimistic building material, arguably too optimistic.
除了审美上的批评，混凝土建筑还带来了环境问题。许多这类建筑建于能源廉价的时代，它们消耗了大量能源来供暖和制冷。混凝土建筑是在“资源充足”的幻觉下建造的，认为我们总是有足够的能源来建造、加热和冷却这些巨大的低效结构。尽管看起来很严酷，但混凝土是一种极其乐观的建筑材料，甚至可以说过于乐观了。
Really from the 1920s, it was seen as being a material that would change the world. It had the potential to build things in a way that hadn't been seen before. Concrete was this material that seemed boundless, readily available in vast quantities, and could create massive spaces unlike any other material. So concrete sprang up everywhere. It's the second most heavily consumed product in the world. The only thing we consume more of than concrete is water. We use concrete for sidewalks, bridges, tunnels, and highways,
实际上从20世纪20年代开始，它就被视为一种将改变世界的材料。它有潜力以一种前所未见的方式建造事物。混凝土这种材料似乎是无限的，可以大量供应，并且可以创造出任何其他材料都无法比拟的巨大空间。因此，混凝土建筑如雨后春笋般出现在各地。它是世界上消费量第二大的产品。我们消费量超过混凝土的唯一东西就是水。我们用混凝土建造人行道、桥梁、隧道和高速公路，
and of course for giant buildings. Whether we're talking about whether we're talking about Stadia or Auditoria or Condominia or Gymnasia or Planetaria. So historically government programs all over the world loved concrete. Particularly in Soviet Russia but also later in Europe North America. It was used for welfare, welfare state projects. Concrete presented the most efficient way to house huge numbers of people. And philosophically, it was seen as humble, capable, and honest. Concrete was just out there in all of its rough glory,
当然还有巨大的建筑。无论我们是在谈论体育场、礼堂、公寓、体育馆还是天文馆。因此，从历史上看，世界各地的政府项目都钟爱混凝土。特别是在苏联，后来也在欧洲和北美。它被用于福利国家项目。混凝土提供了容纳大量人口的最有效方式。从哲学上讲，它被视为谦逊、能干且诚实的。混凝土以其粗犷的荣耀展现出来，
not hiding behind any paint or layers, saying, here I am, love me or hate me. And as Concrete buildings came to signify humility, honesty and integrity. They were erected all over the world as housing projects, court houses, schools, churches, hospitals, and city halls. You'll stand outside and a tour bus will go by and they'll be able to, ladies and gentlemen, voted the most ugliest building in the world, Boston City Hall. How do you compete
不躲在任何油漆或涂层后面，仿佛在说：“我就是这样，爱我也好，恨我也罢。”随着混凝土建筑开始象征谦逊、诚实和正直，它们在世界各地被竖立起来，作为住房项目、法院、学校、教堂、医院和市政厅。你站在外面，一辆旅游巴士经过，导游会说：“女士们先生们，这就是被评为世界上最丑建筑的波士顿市政厅。”你怎么能和
with that? Chris Grimley is up against a lot, but he's trying to restore Boston City Hall's reputation. My name is Chris Grimley. I'm with my fellow heroic people, Mark Paznik and Michael Kubo. Chris, Mark, and Michael have embarked on what they call the heroic project, chronicling the concrete structures in and around Boston. Rather than referring to these concrete buildings as brutalists, they prefer the term heroic, because like so many superheroes, these structures have the best most noble intentions, but are sorely misunderstood. Also, just generally, brutalism is a big, broad label that gets used inconsistently in architecture. People tend to disagree on one precise definition.
那个竞争呢？克里斯·格里姆利面临着很多困难，但他正试图恢复波士顿市政厅的声誉。我叫克里斯·格里姆利。我和我的英雄同伴马克·帕兹尼克和迈克尔·库博在一起。克里斯、马克和迈克尔开始了他们所谓的“英雄项目”，记录波士顿及其周边的混凝土结构。他们不称这些混凝土建筑为“粗野主义”，而更喜欢用“英雄”这个词，因为像许多超级英雄一样，这些结构有着最崇高、最美好的意图，却被严重误解了。此外，总的来说，“粗野主义”是一个宽泛的标签，在建筑学中被不一致地使用。人们往往对一个精确的定义难以达成共识。
The name brutalism also just sounds intense, even though it's not actually related to brutality. It comes from Beton Brute, which is a French term for raw concrete. In any case, to these guys, heroic feels like a better term, especially in Boston, where concrete architecture swooped in and saved the day. You have to situate Boston in late fifties, 1960s. It is America's first city. Well, it is America's most historic city. Again, not really, but I get your point. And yet, it finds itself in the doldrums. Boston, like a lot of other American cities, was plagued by a loss of manufacturing jobs
“粗野主义”这个名字听起来也很强烈，尽管它实际上与“残暴”无关。它来自“Beton Brute”，这是一个法语词，意为“原始混凝土”。无论如何，对这些人来说，“英雄”感觉是一个更好的词，特别是在波士顿，混凝土建筑在那里横空出世，拯救了局面。你必须把波士顿置于50年代末、60年代的背景下。它是美国的第一座城市。好吧，它是美国最具历史意义的城市。再说一次，其实不然，但我明白你的意思。然而，它发现自己处于低谷。波士顿像许多其他美国城市一样，受到制造业工作流失的困扰，
and white flight to the suburbs. And for decades, Boston had the highest property taxes in the nation and almost no development. There is this recognition from civic authorities that something needs to be done and something needs to be done quickly. So Boston sets an agenda to make the city great again, with big, soaring, capable,
以及白人向郊区迁移的困扰。几十年来，波士顿拥有全国最高的房产税，几乎没有任何发展。市政当局认识到必须采取行动，而且必须迅速采取行动。因此，波士顿制定了一个议程，要让这座城市再次伟大，建造宏伟、高耸、能干、
thoroughly modern buildings made, of course, out of concrete. And though some of these buildings were celebrated, others were really not. What we call the third rail of Boston concrete modernism is city hall. When Boston City Hall was built in 1968, critics were put off by this concrete style.
彻底现代化的建筑，当然，是用混凝土建造的。虽然其中一些建筑受到了赞誉，但另一些则不然。我们称之为波士顿混凝土现代主义“第三轨道”的是市政厅。当波士顿市政厅于1968年建成时，评论家们对这种混凝土风格感到反感。
It was called alienating and cold. And since it was a government building, this criticism became impossible to remove from politics. Boston City Hall became a political pawn. Mayors and City Council members kept trying to win public support with promises to get rid of the building. Like John Tobin did when he ran for City Council. Hi everybody, this is John Tobin. Thanks for visiting VotewonTobin.com. Here we are on City Hall Plaza in front of Boston City Hall.
它被称为疏离且冰冷。由于它是政府建筑，这种批评变得无法从政治中剥离。波士顿市政厅成了政治棋子。市长和市议会议员不断试图通过承诺拆除该建筑来赢得公众支持。就像约翰·托宾竞选市议员时所做的那样。大家好，我是约翰·托宾。感谢访问VotewonTobin.com。我们现在在波士顿市政厅前的市政厅广场上。
I'm not in our context, but I know bad eye context when I see it. This is a bad building and I think we can do a lot by knocking this building down. Former Mayor Thomas Manino actually started a study to really look into tearing it down. It turned out as a result of the study that you would need something like a nuclear-grade weapon basically to destroy this building because it was so heavily over-built in concrete. And so when they couldn't tear down City Hall, officials chose to ignore it. People that occupied the building for decades and decades didn't like it and so they didn't invest money into the building and effectively wanted to see the building go away.
我不在我们的背景中，但我一眼就能看出糟糕的背景。这是一座糟糕的建筑，我认为拆掉它我们可以做很多事。前市长托马斯·曼尼诺实际上启动了一项研究，认真考虑拆除它。结果研究表明，你基本上需要某种核武器级别的武器才能摧毁这座建筑，因为它在混凝土方面建造得太过度了。所以当他们无法拆除市政厅时，官员们选择了忽视它。几十年来占据这座建筑的人不喜欢它，所以他们没有向建筑投入资金，实际上是想看着这座建筑消失。
This is called active neglect and it happens with a lot of concrete buildings. They are intentionally unrepaired, unrenovated and uncared for. Which only makes the building more ugly and then more hated and then more ignored and creates this vicious cycle where the public hate of Boston City Hall feeds itself. And then the discussion years on really became about what the original architects had done wrong as if this were not a failure of maintenance but a failure of the initial design.
这被称为“主动忽视”，这种情况发生在许多混凝土建筑身上。它们被故意不修理、不翻新、不照料。这只会让建筑变得更丑，然后更被憎恨，然后更被忽视，从而形成一种恶性循环，公众对波士顿市政厅的仇恨自我滋长。随后的讨论多年来真正变成了关于最初的建筑师做错了什么，就好像这不是维护的失败，而是最初设计的失败。
When people built these mammoth concrete structures, no one really thought about maintenance. They seemed indestructible. In the early days of concrete, people assumed that this was an everlasting material that wouldn't need any attention at all. And I mean, that's wrong. We know that it does need to be looked after. It does deteriorate. It does decay. But it can be hard to tell when concrete is decaying. If you think of brick and timber, the decay takes place on the surface of them.
当人们建造这些巨大的混凝土结构时，没有人真正考虑过维护。它们看起来坚不可摧。在混凝土的早期，人们认为这是一种永恒的材料，根本不需要任何关注。我的意思是，那是错的。我们知道它确实需要被照料。它确实会恶化。它确实会腐烂。但很难判断混凝土何时在腐烂。如果你想到砖块和木材，腐烂发生在它们的表面。
But with concrete, the deterioration is internal. Concrete deteriorates chemically from the inside out. Part of this has to do with the metal reinforcements that help hold up most concrete buildings. The rebar, well they can rust, and the rust eats away at the overall structure. But Adrian 40 says, tearing them down is not the answer. Because as soon as you tear them down, then you have a problem, first of all, what you do with a detritus that's left. And secondly, you've got to replace them with something else and use up a whole lot more energy
但对于混凝土，恶化是内部的。混凝土从内到外发生化学恶化。这部分与帮助支撑大多数混凝土建筑的金属加固物有关。钢筋，它们会生锈，而锈迹会侵蚀整个结构。但阿德里安·福蒂说，拆除它们不是答案。因为一旦你拆除它们，你首先就会遇到一个问题：你如何处理留下的残骸？其次，你必须用其他东西替换它们，并消耗更多的能源，
and create a lot more CO2 in building something in that place. They already used up all that energy when they were made. They're already there. We can adapt these buildings to make them greener and make them more appealing places to be by adding windows, for example. But basically, Professor Forty thinks we can all develop the capacity to love these concrete roots in all their whole game glory.
并在建造那个地方时产生更多的二氧化碳。它们在制造时已经消耗了所有那些能源。它们已经存在了。我们可以改造这些建筑，使它们更环保，并通过增加窗户等方式使它们成为更具吸引力的地方。但基本上，福蒂教授认为我们都可以培养出一种能力，去爱这些混凝土建筑，爱它们所有的粗犷荣耀。
Yeah, sure, people can learn to love anything, but, you know, as with any art form, whether it's opera or painting or literature, the more you know about it, the more you'll get out of it, the more you'll appreciate it. And this is especially true of concrete buildings. Architecture students appreciate them because they know that concrete actually requires a hell of a lot of skill and finesse to work with. To do architecture in concrete is proof that you are really are an architect. It's the test of being an architect. The concrete building, every little detail, needs to be calculated in advance. Concrete is wildly intimidating to work with. Once you pour it, there's no going back. With a concrete building, it's like the result of an immaculate conception. The whole thing is an integral monolithic hole, and it has to be right.
是的，当然，人们可以学会爱任何东西，但是，你知道，正如任何艺术形式一样，无论是歌剧、绘画还是文学，你了解得越多，你得到的就越多，你就会越欣赏它。对于混凝土建筑尤其如此。建筑系学生欣赏它们，因为他们知道混凝土实际上需要极高的技巧和精细度才能使用。用混凝土做建筑证明你确实是一名建筑师。这是成为建筑师的考验。混凝土建筑，每一个小细节，都需要提前计算。使用混凝土工作是非常令人畏惧的。一旦你浇筑了它，就没有回头路了。对于混凝土建筑，它就像是圣母受孕的结果。整个东西是一个完整的整体，它必须是正确的。
And aside from the interesting design challenges that poses, Concrete itself as a material can be subtly beautiful if you look closely. You know what we think of as just a monolithic, consistent, homogenous texture is actually really rich and has a lot of interest when you actually go up to it and consider it. Sarah Briggs Ramsey, the one I spoke with at Berkeley's Worcester Hall, did a year-long project traveling around the world Looking at concrete buildings in Europe and Asia and South and North America to create a global comparison of one material that I think is so
除了它带来的有趣的设计挑战之外，混凝土本身作为一种材料，如果你仔细观察，可以微妙地美丽。你知道我们认为只是单调、一致、均匀的纹理，实际上是非常丰富的，当你真正走近它并思考它时，它有很多趣味。莎拉·布里格斯·拉姆齐，我在伯克利伍斯特大厅采访的那位，做了一个为期一年的项目，环游世界，观察欧洲、亚洲、南美和北美的混凝土建筑，以创造一种单一材料的全球比较，我认为这太
sort of under considered It's like the background of all the cities, but no one actually stands to look. We call the city a concrete jungle to talk about the artificialness of the urban landscape. But concrete can actually be a very natural expression of the environment. Concrete's color and texture can be dictated by local climate, local earth, and local rock. This is the Harvard Science Center on the Harvard campus.
某种程度上被低估了。它就像所有城市的背景，但没有人真正停下来看。我们称城市为“混凝土丛林”来谈论城市景观的人工性。但混凝土实际上可以是环境的一种非常自然的表达。混凝土的颜色和纹理可以由当地气候、当地土壤和当地岩石决定。这是哈佛校园里的哈佛科学中心。
And it's got a very purpley, like a really pronounced purpley color, and that's the ground from the site. Concrete can also be an expression of local style and custom. Like how UK concrete has big, thick, textured chunks of rock while Japanese concrete is very fine and flat. But the beauty of concrete architecture is all the better when you can just observe the buildings like pieces of sculpture without actually having to live and work in them, which brings in concrete, surprising ally, photography.
它有一种非常紫色的，像是一种非常明显的紫色，那是来自场地的土壤。混凝土也可以是当地风格和习俗的表达。就像英国的混凝土有大块、厚实、有纹理的岩石，而日本的混凝土非常细腻平整。但混凝土建筑的美感在你可以像欣赏雕塑一样观察建筑，而不必真正住在里面或在里面工作时，会变得更好，这就引入了混凝土令人惊讶的盟友：摄影。
Concrete looks good in photographs. It provides this kind of neutral background. It provides a wonderful setting for people's skin tones, color of their clothes. Fashion photographers realize this first and then pockets of the internet started to appreciate these concrete buildings. There are lots of these blogs and so on, which show an extraordinary enthusiasm for concrete. Photography is allowing a new audience of non-architects to appreciate these buildings for their strong lines, their crisp shadows, and increasingly the idealism they embody.
混凝土在照片中看起来很好。它提供了一种中性的背景。它为人们的肤色、衣服的颜色提供了一个绝佳的衬托。时尚摄影师首先意识到了这一点，然后互联网的各个角落开始欣赏这些混凝土建筑。有很多这样的博客等等，它们展示了对混凝土的非凡热情。摄影正在让一群新的非建筑师观众因为这些建筑强烈的线条、清脆的阴影以及它们日益体现的理想主义而欣赏它们。
They represent a set of ideas about the state of the world and what the future was imagined to be, that we want to preserve. We should remember what people were thinking 50 years ago. If we tear these buildings down, we will lose all of that. Architecture, whether we want to admit it or not, has a sort of shelf life, a time after which buildings fall out of fashion, and then are allowed to fall apart. Back in the 1960s, Victorian style buildings were considered hideous, falling apart, impossible
它们代表了一套关于世界状态和未来想象的理念，我们想要保留这些。我们应该记住50年前人们在想什么。如果我们拆除这些建筑，我们将失去所有这一切。建筑，无论我们是否愿意承认，都有一定的保质期，过了这个时间，建筑就会过时，然后被允许分崩离析。回到20世纪60年代，维多利亚风格的建筑被认为是丑陋的、分崩离析的、不可能
to repair, and we were tearing batches of them down, all the while erecting big concrete buildings. But enough Victorians were saved that today they are these beautiful, lovingly restored treasures. Brutalist, heroic, whatever you want to call it. Concrete architecture now finds itself at a potential inflection point. Too outdated to be modern, too young to be classic. In a small but growing band of architects,
修复的，我们拆除了一批又一批，同时竖立起巨大的混凝土建筑。但足够多的维多利亚建筑被保存了下来，以至于今天它们成了这些美丽、被精心修复的宝藏。粗野主义、英雄主义，无论你想怎么称呼它。混凝土建筑现在发现自己处于一个潜在的转折点。太老旧而不再现代，太年轻而尚未成为经典。在一小群但不断壮大的建筑师中，
architecture enthusiasts and preservationists would like us to just wait a bit and see. Maybe with a little time and love we might discover some architectural diamonds in the rough that we just can't see right now. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffelman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. 99% invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffelman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to our pal, Allison Areff at Spur, along with Michael Abrinson, the curator of The Beautiful Site, f**k theabrudelism.tumbler.com.
建筑爱好者和保护主义者希望我们稍微等一等，看看。也许随着一点时间和爱，我们可能会发现一些我们现在还看不出来的建筑璞玉。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。特别感谢我们的朋友，Spur的艾莉森·阿雷夫，以及《美丽场所》的策展人迈克尔·阿布林森，f**k theabrudelism.tumbler.com。
Additional thanks to Renee Tap and Arkside Zone, the Fannual Mueller. The book, Heroic, Concrete Architecture, and the new Boston will be out in October. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced by the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interior sperm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. Our pal Melodium, whose music I'm talking about right now, has a new mini album called Beneath for sale on Bandcamp. It's pay what you want, so be generous. He's one of the good guys and he makes this show so much better.
还要感谢蕾妮·塔普和Arkside Zone，以及Fannual Mueller。书籍《英雄：混凝土建筑与新波士顿》将于十月出版。我们是91.7 KALW旧金山的一个项目，由ArcSign办公室制作，这是一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司。我们的朋友Melodium，我刚才谈论的音乐就是他的，他在Bandcamp上有一张名为《Beneath》的新迷你专辑在售。这是“随心支付”的，所以请慷慨解囊。他是好人之一，他让这个节目变得好多了。
Go to Melodium.bandcamp.com and just buy all of his albums and walk around as if you're in an episode of 99% invisible all the time. That's what I do. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. If you're in an episode of 99% of visible all the time, that's what I do. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, I'm at Roman Mars. Avery is at Truffleman Katie Mingle, is at Katie Mingle, and Sam Greenspan is at Sam Lissons.
去Melodium.bandcamp.com买下他所有的专辑，走在街上就像你一直生活在《99%隐形》的一集里一样。我就是这么做的。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。如果你一直生活在《99%隐形》的一集里，我就是这么做的。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter上，我是@RomanMars。艾弗里是@Truffleman，凯蒂·明格尔是@KatieMingle，萨姆·格林斯潘是@SamLissons。
We're also on Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but you can listen to every single episode of 99% invisible at 99p.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，但你可以在99p.org收听《99%隐形》的每一集。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。